some businesses are just easier to build
on the scale than others some businesses
have a high growth market and some of
them are slow growth it doesn't mean
that you can't win but the opportunity
is going to be much different the upside
is going to be much different depending
on the market that you're going into I'd
love to say that a successful
entrepreneur is one who combines what
you love doing with the world as an
opportunity if you love doing it but
there's no opportunity or it's really
small then you've got a hobby it can be
really fulfilling hobby but it's when
you love doing it and there's a big
opportunity that's when you start to win
now if there's a big opportunity you
don't love doing it you're not going to
win either you can build an okay
business if there's a big opportunity
but you don't like doing it but only for
so long because then you're gonna quit
you're gonna hate your life because
you're waking up every day and doing
work that you don't like doing and
you're gonna quit this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle they do one of
those two things they try to start a
business just around their hobby what
they're passionate about but there's no
Market opportunity they don't know how
to tie it into real demand so they never
build a business just a hobby on the
weekends in new things or they're just
chasing the hot opportunity and they
don't care about the business and so
either way you're going to lose in both
those scenarios you win by doing the
work that you love that has a big
opportunity upside to you as well hey
it's Nina Carmichael and we made these
videos because you're probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you need
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Evan Carmichael
and learn how to set up your business
for Success enjoy
foreign
examples uh that happened to me in the
past week that I think could be really
relevant and valuable one was that a
dear friend of mine asked me what social
media platforms am I focusing on and
we're talking about Instagram because he
he wants to go more hardcore and
Instagram want to know what I was doing
on Instagram and I said you know what
right now I'm not doing much on
Instagram
you know I'm not spending a lot of my
effort my time my energy on Instagram I
love serving I love helping I love
getting a message out there I want to do
it in a way that has the biggest
potential for impact and reach in the
projects I'm working on so he said well
where are you spending your effort and
energy well YouTube was still number one
YouTube was number one because YouTube
is still the best place to get your
message across
it has been for the past couple years
and it's only getting bigger more people
are going to YouTube for content for
Education it's only getting bigger so
YouTube is still number one but then
after YouTube where am I spending most
of my time
Twitter
and Discord
Discord I think is the best place to be
for community and Twitter
it's surprising how how much Twitter has
picked up Twitter was one of the first
social networks I was on and I I not
left it but kind of ignored it for years
and now it's back it's back baby
so I'm spending a lot of my time on
Twitter and Discord and of course
YouTube and why well because that's
where people are that's where the impact
is that's where you get your message out
and so I don't care about the platform I
care about reaching people so you could
spend all day long working on on
Instagram or you could have spent all
day long still if you were working on
MySpace creating your account does
mystery still exist I don't even know
it's just not a big opportunity
and so yeah again what do I care about I
care about helping entrepreneurs I care
about getting a message out there so
then it becomes using your head okay
where's the opportunity YouTube Discord
Twitter PS if you want to join my
Discord server it's free I'm there every
day Evan carmichael.biz come check us
out
example was I'm talking to a successful
entrepreneur who wants to move from his
big business that he's built tens of
millions of dollars in Revenue to
starting a business to help other
entrepreneurs get their companies going
and he's having a hard time getting this
thing off the ground and is having a
hard time monetizing it
[Music]
and he's having a hard time getting
people to pay him for things
and I said well the immediate
opportunity you know if you have a long
Horizon great you'll you'll eventually
win because your brain will play out
you'll get better at them at the game
Etc but
the best thing that you can do right now
if you want to monetize it is coach
people who are
inside of your industry that you have
domain expertise because what he's
coming at doing is just helping people
with personal development coming in
helping them believe in themselves
helping them overcome their living
beliefs you know helping them
fix their mindset get their schedule
right all that stuff but then if they're
off building their own business
he's only adding one little piece now
imagine if you could add the tactical
information and the contacts as well as
the mindset and the motivation so
there's two entrepreneurs three
entrepreneurs that I invested into
recently Drew
Jeremy and Beau and these three guys
some of them had no experience I think
Jeremy had it was a stock boy at a
grocery store and you know he's mid six
figures Revenue 18 months later why well
because yes I'm giving him the belief in
the mindset and the motivation but I can
also give him contacts I can also make
introductions for him I can also give
him information about the industry to
know
what he's doing right and what he's
doing wrong and so when I'm looking at
making an investment into an
entrepreneur I want to be able to help
them Beyond just believe because I can
get believed to anybody but whoever I
want to give believe to that had the
highest impact for Success it's going to
be people who I can give contacts to
Jeremy does YouTube Consulting there's
people who contact me all the time for
YouTube Consulting I don't want to do it
I don't want to be in that business so I
can give it to Jeremy perfect but if you
were a you know I don't know you were an
arborist can you see the trees I guess
not it's kind of blurry if you're an
arborist I could help you believe in
yourself I can give you some business
model ideas but I can't make contacts or
introductions for you
and so you have to be smart about the
opportunities you take on
it has to be something that you
deeply deeply deeply care about
and then inside that find the
opportunity
because the market is moving and the
market hopefully is getting bigger and
if you're inside a growing market and
you love what you're doing that's a slam
dunk that's a home run for you so
what's the methodology now to help
figure that out well one you have to
start with what do you naturally just
love doing what do you love doing what
can you wake up and get what do you what
are you getting lost in where are you
spending your time what are you
daydreaming about don't not about the
result not about the cars and the yachts
and the whatever right not that that
that's a result that what do you get
lost in the process of doing what
industry do you actually care about
where are you spending your time where
are you researching what doesn't feel
like work for you right so that's Step
One is is connecting to something that
you're actually passionate about not
just trying to make money right make
money is important but it's not step
number one
figure out that idea next is okay how do
we turn that into a market opportunity
where is the business actually growing
that we can connect our our talents and
our passions to so if you love send if
you love sharing a message like my first
example great now be strategic about the
platform that you're gonna pick
it used to be Instagram now it's YouTube
Twitter and Discord
if you love coaching people and
Consulting and investing in people great
connected to where you actually have
domain expertise and can make
introductions for people and take a
piece of their business as opposed to
just charging for the hour or just
helping people with mindset and not
actually introductions and tactics right
so you love the opportunity it makes you
come alive thinking about it and
there's actually something for you to
grow right logically strategically is a
way for you to make money doing it when
you can combine those two things you
have a much much much much much much
much higher degree of success
number two bring value I think most
people are confused about money most
people don't have a healthy relationship
with money
there are the people who think that
money is everything the money is the
only important thing in the world and
you need to chase it down and is your
duty and responsibility obligations like
it's number one the person walking into
my house or my place of business that's
my next suit that's my next payment
that's my next whatever it's only
focused on money
and there's other people who think money
is the root of all
evil
and that money is a bad thing
money is a tool money helps you get a
lot of things done money helps you go
places money helps you accomplish your
mission money needs to be in your top
five
it's just not number one money needs to
be in your top five if money does not
become important at some point to you if
it's not in your top five priorities
you'll never make money and you'll
always be by yourself struggling trying
to figure out how to make something work
but it's not number one either if you
put money above all else you'll end up
doing a lot of work that you hate and
you never get good at it just because
you're chasing opportunities this is a
big reason why so many entrepreneurs
fail you're just chasing the hottest
thing for this year that you don't have
a passion or interest in and then you
lose because the people who love that
destroy you
when I first started doing this helping
entrepreneurs I never thought I was
going to make money
my first speaking gig my first option to
help people was in Canada in my hometown
of Toronto was at a YMCA it was a free
event they had an entrepreneurship
program and they asked me to come and
speak to their members it was free I
wasn't getting paid to do it just wanted
to help out I just sold my business I
wanted to give back I was saying yes to
everything I actually didn't even know
what I wanted to do next
and so I show up
and this is big room full of chairs and
only three people show up to that first
event
only three people
and as soon as I walked in the room and
I saw three people my heart sank
I felt like I'm never going to be able
to make anything from this if only three
people show up to a free event how am I
ever going to make money from it
I didn't know
but I keep my best to those three people
I know that I help those three people
and had an impact on their lives we then
went for coffee afterwards and continue
the conversation I know that I helped
them and it filled my soul and I had to
find a way to keep doing it I knew I had
to find a way to keep doing it even if I
never made money and so I did I kept
doing speaking gigs I did my website I
did my YouTube channel and slowly slowly
slowly slowly
it started to come in as I figured out
the second key important piece
which is figuring out how to bring value
to other people when you find something
that you love doing
and you combine it with how it brings
value to other people that's when you
start making money
if it's something that you just love
doing
but nobody else likes it there's zero
value to anybody else you have a hobby
you have a hobby
if you're only chasing stuff that people
like and need but you don't like doing
it
you're never going to get great at it
you might make a little bit of money but
you're never gonna get great at it
you're never gonna be all time you're
never going to build a huge business
and so it's that combination
of doing work that you love doing and
mix it with where does an opportunity
that people need it's a problem that you
are solving mix those things together
you have a super successful business
I profiled so many different
entrepreneurs over the years
and the number one rule that comes up
over and over and over and over and over
again is you have to love the process
you have to love the work you have to
love what it is that you're doing
because most people would quit when it
gets too hard the thing that allows you
to keep going and keep trying and keep
struggling and keep pushing forward even
in the face of all of this no and
negativity and obstacles and things in
your way why keep doing this thing
because you love it because you love the
process you have to get addicted to love
in the process and not just the results
the results are great the results of
winning the results of making money
amazing great but you have to love the
process
people who win they love the game they
love the process they love the journey
they love the work however you want to
call it and that's across Athletics
entrepreneurship science innovation
everything
it's the most consistent rule that
successful High achieving people have in
common
and so then that's your job one fix your
relationship with money
understand that money is not number one
but it's not evil either it's not number
100 even if you're a charity you need to
learn how to make money it's got to be
in your top five but it's number two
three four or five not number one and
then part two is you have to figure out
how can you combine the thing that you
absolutely love doing
in a way that brings value to other
people in a big way
and when you figure out what that
intersection looks like now you're
starting to make a lot of money and
having an impact and changing the world
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free work sheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
number three keep making progress with a
push pass failure is to keep making
progress part of the reasons why you
stick on failure and feeling so bad
about yourself and it's never going to
work out it's because there's nothing
new that you're working on that's
exciting that you're building towards
that you feel like you're making
progress on because when you're making
progress and you're moving forward you
can't feel like a failure and you don't
have time to think about the failures
that you've had
people ask me all the time hey what do
you do when one of your videos fail like
videos fail all the time my videos fail
all the time all the time and can I
learn from them yes and can we look at
the data and the analytics and show hey
when this happened your video tanked yes
and we do that and we learn from it but
I don't have time to sit there and look
at
all of just a failures and sit on it
because I've got more videos that I need
to make another video is coming out
tomorrow and another videos came out the
next day another videos coming out the
next day and I don't know how many
videos we put out every day across all
of our channels but it's a lot of
content and I'm so focused on the next
thing that I'm less focused on the one
that was so learn from that awesome now
move forward and when you don't have
anything that you're moving forward
towards that's when it starts to really
hit hard
um and so that's
I think it's really important I think we
get too caught up on our first one and
it'd be an amazing and nobody liking it
and so we're gonna stop and and even for
me my first video I figured how many
months it was between my first video of
all time and then my second video but it
was a while before I kept going because
the first video didn't do as well as I
thought I I would do uh I wasn't as good
as I thought it was going to be I was
way more nervous than I thought it was
going to be and I got no comments right
it's like my mom and my sister commented
on my video and I felt like a failure so
I stopped going
and the thing that saved me the most
over however many years of making videos
the decade plus has been you keep going
you keep making content you keep
creating you put it in your calendar and
you keep doing something to build
momentum towards a dream that you
and so I think that's incredibly
valuable whether you're going through a
big failure or a mini failure I think it
helps when I look at big failures in my
life right so a video failing that's a
small failure right like this if this
video doesn't go and blow up it's a
small failure but big failures the two
biggest ones was one personal and one
business the business one is my in my
first company we I quit I'm a business
partner I just I felt like a loser I was
not making money writing making 300
bucks a month having no results no
traction I just feel like a total
failure and nothing was working out and
I told my business partner that I quit
and the thing that got me through it was
eventually just realizing hey somebody
else has done this
I can model success and I looked at Bill
Gates and how he started Microsoft and I
learned from that and built my company
but it was that the progress the moving
forward instead of being stuck on how
everything sucks and I suck and I'm not
getting results and I'm just failing the
thing that got me the energy to keep
going was
feeling like this progress towards a new
idea or a new strategy to help me
accomplish my goals my biggest personal
failure was getting divorced over 10
years ago and that was that was really
rough you know it was a personal it felt
like a personal failure I mean it ended
up being the best thing for both of us
but at the time it felt like a huge
failure even just saying that I you know
am divorced
um it just felt like a a giant failure
that I suck as a human that that I
couldn't make this work and
that took a while to get through and
eventually the thing that
that helped me was
I pulled up a dating app and I saw uh
options you know I was like oh you know
what okay this could maybe maybe this
could work or or that could work and
it's like
idea of progress
towards something instead of being stuck
in the past is the thing that started to
get me through to build some momentum
understand that if you're living in
Failure right now it's it's just the
past you're living in the past you're
you're frustrated with what what
happened and what you should have done
differently and could have done
differently and you wish you said this
or did that or acted a certain way
you're just constantly repeating the
past where to get out of the past to get
out of failure now we need to think
present and future what are we working
towards what are we building towards
what are we creating and making and as
soon as you can shift from past to
present or future that starts to allow
your your brain to shift into for
momentum and progress instead of living
in Failure so some of the steps that you
you can do that I think can help one
put activity into your calendar
so whatever you're working towards if it
didn't work out once awesome put in your
calendar to keep going
today's a Tuesday as I'm filming this
video Tuesday is my video day I'm I'm
making content on Tuesday
you know we're here and we're sitting in
the parking lot my my wife Nina is
running some errands doing shipping out
some built to serve books I believe
right now here at the shipping center
and I'm making content because it's in
my calendar if I didn't have content day
and it wasn't scheduled in I wouldn't be
making content I'd be doing something
else or I might be thinking about all
the past failures that I had in my
content but because this is scheduled in
my calendar I'm making progress and
moving forward so whatever you want to
make progress and move forward towards
have chunks of time in your calendar
dedicated to doing it two have something
that inspires you it could be people it
could be remembering what impact you're
trying to have your big mission or your
vision you're trying to accomplish one
of the things that really helped me
early in my career is I made a
PowerPoint file of all the people who
came to my events my my seminars my
speaking gigs and
the message that they had for me they
wrote to me because I feel great the
next day after an event but then I would
I would lose the vibe and lose the
momentum that didn't feel like who cares
it doesn't matter anymore but I would I
would watch his PowerPoint file where I
put their quotes and how much of an
impact that was having on them and so it
reminded me of why I do what I do and
gave me more energy momentum to keep
moving forward that becomes critical
like what inspires you to want to move
forward maybe it's watching videos like
this maybe it's looking at testimonials
from the people who who you've helped
maybe it's remembering your big goal and
dream of what you're trying to
accomplish but what inspires you to want
to start building some momentum and then
three model success and find the people
who are doing the thing or have done the
thing that you're trying to do and learn
from them and study them and what that
does is it gives you
hope and strategies
when you are studying people who've done
the thing that you want to do it gives
you the hope that it's possible for you
too right because when you look at their
story they probably started with less
than what you have right now and in
studying them you can see oh if they
could do it maybe I can too it's just
that hope because you don't see anybody
in your family your friend's Circle
doing what you want to do and so it
feels impossible but when you're around
the people who are doing it even just by
reading their book or watching their
videos it gives you the hope that it's
possible and then two it gives you the
strategy of what you could be doing so
how do you go from where you are now to
where you want to be well if you're
modeling success and you see what they
did it gives you hope plus the strategy
to actually go off and execute so coming
back to the theme of failure what this
video is all about you're gonna have
tons of failure it's gonna happen like
if you are not failing it means you're
not taking a big enough shot right if
you're if you're not failing you're just
doing things that you know how to do
therefore you're just in your comfort
zone therefore you just hate your life
right if you're not if you have zero
failure happening in your life then
you're taking zero chances and you're
just doing what you know how to do and
you'll be bored and you won't like your
life so recognize that failure is a part
of the process and as soon as we can
move from past I suck as a human I made
all these mistakes too okay I'm moving
forward we're making progress we got a
big thing that we're chasing down when
you can move from failure to progress it
gives you the momentum it gives you the
hope it gives you the energy and ends up
giving you a lot better results as well
rule number four I play to win most
people are so afraid to lose that they
don't even try so when you have nothing
when you're at the bottom you've got
nothing to lose and so it's very easy to
go off and try but as soon as there are
Stakes as soon as you've won just a
little bit now you risk losing something
and this is where most people back down
and play small for life and so so you
need to decide are you playing life to
win or are you playing life afraid to
lose so I look at my YouTube channel as
an example when I started it there was
no risk nobody knew me nobody's watching
my videos I could go and fail didn't
make a difference I could try a whole
bunch of different things whenever the
algorithm changed I got pumped because
the people who are ahead of me were
complaining and would would be romantic
and would want it to go back the way it
was and I'm like hey algorithm change
amazing let's go I'm gonna learn that
new thing
but now I've gotten bigger
right now I think I have more views than
anybody in The Entrepreneur Space on
YouTube and it's easy to now be
protective it's easy to say well I built
this thing I don't want to lose and I
hate that I need to I need to destroy
that I want to be constantly losing
constantly testing constantly risking no
not risking at all not not putting
everything on the line just for one
thing but to be willing to test willing
to fail as an example
I split up my channels
I split up my channels into eight
different channels I got an advice from
Matt Gillan he's one of five people who
who are put on my hand as people who I
listened to for YouTube advice right
here's one of the five and another one
of the five said don't do it so I got
five people who I listen to about
YouTube one person says split up your
channel one person says don't do it what
do I do I have to do it just to see
because I know what not splitting on my
channel looks like it's what I'm
currently doing
but splitting on my channel I won't know
if it's gonna work or not until I
actually go off and do it and so I did
and here's a news flash it's not working
yet right my other channels the most I
think has 8 000 subscribers they have
two around 8 000 subscribers and the
others are smaller and they're growing
every day and they're getting a momentum
every day but overall my subscriber
growth is down My Views are down my
revenue is down everything is down it's
all down watch time was down everything
is down is it a big failure I don't know
maybe I'm gonna give it more time and
see
I'm gonna give it more time and see it's
a risk right I went from making three
videos a day on one channel to making
one video a day across a couple channels
and then you know once a week on some
channels and we have eight different
channels now it's more headache it's
more management maybe ultimately it will
work out or maybe in six months I'll
come back and say man that was a giant
failure that sucked
but I won't know until they try and
that's that's where you need to risk it
that's where you need to try you need to
see you need to test you need to taste
it because if I just take that mindset
every time of saying well this is what's
always worked and so I need to protect
this and stay true to this and that's it
I can never change one I'm gonna
eventually hate my life I'm gonna hate
my business because you need to evolve
you need to change you need to grow what
what got you success is amazing but if
you if you then do that same thing over
and over and over forever you're gonna
feel like you got yourself a job why did
you leave your job to do this thing to
have creativity and freedom and fun not
to do the same thing over and over and
over and over and over again right you
have to evolve your business as you
evolve as a human or or your business
will start to flounder and suffer and it
happens to so many entrepreneurs you see
this growth and then you see this
Plateau this long plateau and people
start to get more and more bored with
their business and with their life
because they're not evolving their
business as they evolved as humans right
so if I did that with my YouTube channel
I would I would start to struggle and
suffer and you see it with a lot of
YouTubers now maybe in in six months I
end up going back right or maybe I never
go back but there's always going to be
some new iterations some new versions
some new thing that I'm willing to risk
even though I've grown my channel I'm
I'm among the biggest in the space
and so always having that mindset I want
to win
I want to win I want to keep pushing I I
want to just not play life trying not to
lose
and so when again at the beginning it's
easy
but once you start building something up
and that's in your business that's in
your relationships like your
relationship will need to evolve too
what got you there is a good starting
point but you're going to evolve and and
your spouse or your boyfriend girlfriend
they're gonna evolve too and can you
evolve together I think the test of a
relationship is how much can you evolve
together
because if you're growing and learning
and improving yourself and and your
partner is just staying still you're
eventually going to grow apart or if
your partner's going a different way
you're going to grow apart even faster
but you're gonna grow nobody just wants
to stay static forever and so can you
weave and grow together that's the game
so you have to decide are you planning
to win or you're playing just not to
lose so how do you played a win I'm
going to give you a three-step process
that I think can help set number one is
used to fear of regret use regret regret
is very powerful because if you look at
people who are at the end of their life
in old age homes who can't do it anymore
who can't chase their goals anymore if
they're filled with regret like I I knew
I had potential I knew I could have done
something but I didn't because I was
just too afraid
use that power for yourself you're
afraid to do something you're afraid to
change you're afraid to to risk
something you're gonna be 95 you're
gonna be on your deathbed soon like
imagine you're there right now
and you never took the thing that you
wanted to do you never got an answer you
never chased it down because you were
afraid
you're gonna you're gonna hate your life
that's where most people lie but the
good news is you can come back to to
this year right you can step back into
your body right now and say I can do it
and so adopting the mindset that you
would rather know and fail than not know
not knowing equals regret forever
knowing and failing you can deal with it
you very rarely regret the things that
you do
it's most often the things that you did
not do that you were afraid to do the
actions not taken that people regret and
so don't be like that whenever you're
afraid of doing something take that test
use the regret test imagine yourself at
95 in a rocking chair in an old age home
and you never did the thing that you're
thinking about right now would you
regret that and whatever you think that
you would regret not doing you have to
summon the courage to do it right now
step number two is understand that your
setback primes your comeback your
setbacks prime your comebacks nobody's
on top always right it says drop and
then you come back even higher
and so whatever you want to go off and
do right whatever change you want to go
off and make
chances are one is not fatal like you
can always come back to something
right if you want to take a year off
after University to go be an
entrepreneur instead of going to that
job where if you're if you're in a job
that you hate you say you know what I
can always get another job so I'm going
to try for a year doing my own business
it's not fatal you can always come back
and do it you can always come back and
get that crappy job you know you're
capable of it you know you're probably
more than capable of it of what you're
doing right now but the thing is you're
probably not going to go back to it
right like you're leaving it for a
reason you don't go back to your
ex-girlfriend or ex-boyfriend you go
back to that crappy boss because in that
time even though you may have failed a
whole bunch of times you've learned and
you've grown you're a stronger person
because of it it's that setback primes
you for your comeback because now you're
a stronger person you're capable of more
and you'll find the next PATH the path
that you chose may not be the ultimate
path for you but you know that the path
you left is not the path for you either
and so better than sticking on some path
that you know that you don't love
it's better to go off and explore the
test The Taste is to try most people
don't do that enough and they're so
worried about the failure you're worried
about this New Path failing and not
working out
you can tell yourself you can always go
back to that thing and you can and the
facts are you can't you can go back and
do what you're doing before
which probably won't even if the thing
that you jump to doesn't work out
you're not going back to where you were
because you're strong you've grown and
that'll set you up for the comeback
that'll set you up for the next great
thing in your life because you won't
find the great thing doing the thing
that you hate doing and step number
three is say it's the best
I've trained myself that whenever
something really negative is happening
to me I say this is the best
this is the best
what was the best part of me going on my
tour for 90 days 23 cities breaking my
neck broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion three stables in my head I
still have you can kind of see down
there
how do I point right there right there
got got my my two neck braces that I had
to sleep in and be in basically all day
long except for a 10 minute shower that
was the best part of the tour
not just positive attitude like it's the
best
actually the best because that negative
situation that that you're dealing with
right now
makes you stronger it shows you what
you're capable of thank you your purpose
comes from your pain ultimately right
like the thing that you want to do for
the rest of your life comes from the
most painful moment in your life
whatever you struggle the most with is
the thing that you want to help other
people through
and so thank you for that crazy pain
somebody hasn't been through pain never
accomplishes anything amazing so thank
you this pain that I'm that I'm going
through right now amazing let's go this
is the best
if you could just change that mindset
tweak the next time you find yourself
complaining angry upset frustrated tell
yourself just try it this is the best
this is the best this is my chance to
show myself in the world what I'm made
of this is my chance to grow this is the
best
and watch how quickly it puts you into a
resourceful State instead of being
hopeless and complaining and upset and
frustrated now you feel like things are
possible
now you feel hopeful now you're
resourceful and now you're way more
likely to solve the problem instead of
sitting there complaining about it
number five the last one before our very
special bonus clip tell your story your
story is your competitive Advantage why
you do what you do where you came from
your history all of the the baggage the
imperfections the vulnerability all of
that your story is the thing that's
going to help you win as an entrepreneur
this is one of the biggest
misconceptions and one of the hardest
things for us to do as entrepreneurs to
put ourselves out there and share the
story we want to be perfect we see these
big Brands we see people popping off on
Instagram and their perfect life and
their perfect planes and their perfect
marketing and we feel not good enough
and we feel like we have to be like them
but people can smell through it think
about it you're going up against some
big company right whatever industry
you're in there's some big players more
establishing you bigger budgets than you
deeper Pockets than you they've been
there forever they've got the brand name
the history the reputation people know
who they are and you're going up against
them why would somebody buy from you
instead of them
to your story
because you're gonna make me feel
special because in you I see myself I
see somebody who cares I see somebody
who's going to go off and make a
difference where I have no connection to
big company to Big Corporation but what
most entrepreneurs do is they try to
look the part of being the big corporate
they have a really formal website they
have a really formal
Photography they have a really formal
bio
yeah at best you're going to be a junior
junior junior version of that big
company
I need to know why you do what you do
this is how you win your heart is your
competitive advantage
why do you care so much and if you
believe like I believe that your purpose
comes from your pain that whatever
you're doing right now your deep purpose
is to help other people who currently
are who you used to be then I need to
know what pain you've come through
because you might have the answers you
might have the solution your product
your service your coaching your content
whatever could actually be the solution
but until I know that you've come
through the thing that I'm struggling
with I'm not going to listen to you
because I'm going to think yeah right
this person doesn't get it this person
doesn't understand me this person
doesn't care
meanwhile you do care meanwhile it's the
most important thing meanwhile you care
way more than anybody else cares but
until you actually share your story
nobody's gonna listen
this is one of the hardest things for me
to overcome when I started my business
because I always felt well nobody cares
about my story who cares it's not about
me I I have no need to be in front of a
camera I'm introverted and shy by Nature
I know you may not believe that watching
these videos but I am and I remember
fighting with my agent Steve many times
everyone that Steve nobody cares about
what I've done and my story and I don't
I don't like the spotlight on me so why
does it matter and after years of
fighting hopefully what took me forever
to figure out if you guys get this in
this video you'll be way further ahead
than I was when I was getting started
people learn through your story and if
you've got a message
you telling your story actually
perpetuates the message so you telling
your story it's not about you and your
ego and how you look and how people see
you and prizes and awards and anything
it's about making an impact because when
I know that you've been through what I'm
going through or I know how much you
care about something I'm much more
likely to want to hire you so let me
give you a couple examples
I remember I was doing a radio show and
when I first got started uh in in
coaching it was through a live radio
show that I was doing once a week I
remember one person calling in and he
had a landscaping business
and that's okay well what's so different
about your Landscaping Company because
he was frustrated that all of these
teenagers and high school kids were
eating up his business where I say hey
we'll landscape your yard and we'll do
it for minimum wage and here he is
trying to make more than minimum wage
and he's worried that he has to compete
on price and he can't do it against his
teenagers and so I said well why do you
why do you care so much about
Landscaping man like why did you pick
this business and I hope for all of you
please that you have a story right if
you're picking a business just to make
money you've lost already
You've Lost That the entrepreneur
success formulas you got to combine what
you love doing with what brings value to
other people you have to love it you
have to have a story if there's no Story
You've Lost go pick something else that
you actually can't connect to
but I asked why did you start this
business what does it mean to you and he
said
my mom was my hero
and when I was young
she always took me out to the yard and
we did landscaping together
and it's always a connection to her
and then there was a line that he said
that really caught me where he said
every lawn that I go to every customer's
lawn that I go help I treat it like it's
my mom's lawn
and right there it's like oh my gosh
this guy cares so much like do you think
the average high school after school
summer job do you think they care as
much about your yard as this guy does
right if he's treating it like it's his
mom's Garden
and by sharing that story now you'd be
willing to pay more I'd be willing to
pay him way more than than a high school
kid because I think that he's gonna give
a way better service provide way more
value because I understand the story but
if I just went to the website and I
looked at his services and I go to some
giant Corporation who does it or I go to
see some teenager who does it the
website's gonna look pretty similar the
services are going to look pretty
similar but the heart and soul is the
thing that's missing that's why he's
gonna give the best value compared to
the other extremes same thing for you
you love the thing that you're doing I
hope if not find something else you love
the thing that you're doing
I need to understand your passion I need
to see it and people are you're afraid
of of not looking good on camera you're
afraid of not being articulate that
doesn't matter I'm not hiring a
landscaping company based off of how
professional their video is
often the more professional it is the
worse it is because when there's big
lights and cameras and setups and
everything else you get a lot more
nervous like oh my gosh you got all
these people watching me I better
deliver and then you end up giving a
really boring fake uh nervous scared
anxiety version of your story that
nobody's gonna connect to
take out your phone and press record
I don't care if there's background music
or lower thirds or the perfect lights or
microphone if you're a landscaping
company now if you're a videographer
your stuff better be on fire it better
be on point because I'm hiring you to
produce a video but if you're a
landscaping company or something totally
different has nothing to do with video
production the most important thing is
for you to be able to get your story out
there to be creative to be authentic to
imagine that there's somebody here that
you're talking to instead of just a
camera to get your message out there
that is why people will buy from you
that is why people will connect with you
that is why people will listen to you
because they feel like you deeply deeply
deeply deeply care about this thing and
I know you do
but it's just not anywhere I can't find
it on your social I can't find it on
your YouTube I can't find it on your
website I can't find it anyone not the
heart because you're trying to be
perfect and professional like big
Corporation
your story is your competitive advantage
one of the things that really helped me
was leaning into
the fact that I'm shy and introverted
and afraid to get in front of the camera
and afraid to get on stage and no need
to be famous that's led to actually a
lot of opportunities
[Laughter]
the more I lean in on those things the
more things come to me I remember doing
a speech at Brandon burchard's growth
event and
I wasn't as myself I was more
professional I was more just given
advice great great advice people loved
it and then he invited me back to speak
at his uh private Mastermind and now
this these groups are paying 30 to 50
000 to be in that room so now there's
higher pressure you know like the first
one the ticket was gonna be 100 bucks
the ticket to this one is thirty
thousand dollars to fifty thousand
dollars like oh my gosh extra pressure
and I just leaned in on it
I I walked up on stage and I I came
after Dean graziosi so Dean spoke and
then it was me and Dean was using the
Flipboard
uh you know this is like a paper beside
you and you're you're flipping one page
at a time and I'd never used a Flipboard
in in any of my presentations I've had
PowerPoint in the past or I normally
just get up and talk but I thought okay
I'm gonna try and use the Flipboard and
I didn't know how to use it I I always
felt like I was blocking somebody uh so
I'm hiding behind the Flipboard trying
to write it and it ended up being really
funny and um
Brendan took me aside after and he said
that was the best that was so much
better than you did at in Arizona at my
first event and Arizona was great but
like you need to lean in on your
goofiness you need to lean in on your
shyness you need to lean in on the
things that make you nervous if you're
if you're nervous say you're nervous if
you have anxiety say you have anxiety
um I I've LED with something like that
it's like I'm I'm scared I'm an
introvert I'm shy and I've got my heart
beating like crazy right now standing up
here in front of all you guys that's how
it led my speech something like that
um and so leaning in on that has helped
has helped me it's a lot more real
yeah it's a lot more real so you don't
feel like you have to be fake you can
just lean in on the thing that makes
your heart go crazy like this lean in on
it if you were to make a video to say I
want to tell you my story
now if I go back to the landscaping
company I want to tell you why I do what
I do and normally I hate making videos
and this makes me really anxious and
nervous and I'm scared to do this but
Landscaping is just so important
it's so important to me because and then
you tell the story with the mom wouldn't
you want to hire that person wouldn't
you want to pay more for that person
right so leaning in on your story on the
thing that you're worried that you're
going to get judged for is the way that
you're gonna win
your story is your competitive Advantage
stop trying to be perfect stop trying to
go up against these big corporations and
feel like you have to be fancy like them
where all you're doing is being boring
being vanilla and being a junior junior
junior junior version of them
your story is your competitive Advantage
you need to start getting it out there
the thing that makes you go boom boom
boom boom boom boom like that
that's what you have to share and that's
how you start to win
when do you quit you quit when you don't
love it anymore if you quit now but you
still love it you will regret that
decision the rest of your life you'll
constantly wonder what if I just gave it
one more day one more week one more
month you might have to slow down and do
something else to survive but you have
to keep going if you still love it so I
look at my early days as a YouTube
Creator and you can go back on my
channel and see how awkward I was and
nervous I was and my first video I'm
sitting down in a suit and a tie and uh
and I'm sweating and I'm trying to
memorize my lines and took me all day to
make one video most of my lines were me
reading because I couldn't memorize the
entire script and I was so afraid of not
having to be perfect with my lines and
so I read most of it and had b-roll on
top of it but still it took me a whole
day just to get some of those lines out
on cameras like take after take after
take after take after take and when I
started
on paper it looked like a stupid idea I
had no video background I was I'm
introverted it doesn't come across now
but I'm introverted I don't like being a
center of attention I don't go in and
talk to people to introduce myself I
don't like the camera being on me I
don't like being in a spotlight it
doesn't doesn't make me feel amazing
about myself I don't crave it I'd much
rather be at home by myself you know
with my wife that's super comfortable
for me that's easy so when I started it
was just an experiment
and even though I wasn't very good at it
I just loved it
I don't know I liked it I'm a visual
learner
and I think people are built to serve
right and I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur that I I wish there was
more content for entrepreneurs that was
Visual and that model success Bill Gates
saved my company not not me talking to
him or him investing in my business just
his story how he started I applied and
that started growing my company and I
wish there were more resources telling
the stories of successful famous
entrepreneurs that you could learn from
one just get inspired to say wow look
what they can do but two also to get
specific ideas to help you grow your
business and it didn't exist and so I
thought I'm gonna go make it right
typical entrepreneur nothing exists in
the market so I'm gonna go off and
create it myself
and so it made me do all these things
that I was afraid of that I wasn't good
at that I didn't have natural talent in
and it took me five years to get to my
first 7 000 subscribers right think
about that Journey now I wasn't doing it
every day I wasn't as hardcore committed
I was experimenting and playing with it
a bunch before actually taking it
seriously but I loved it
even now I love it like as much as I'm
afraid to get in front of the camera or
afraid to go and do a speech because I
don't want to disappoint people I still
love it I love it I love serving I love
helping people this is what I this is
what I need to do and so even though I
wasn't seeing a lot of momentum or
traction at the beginning even though
all this stuff on paper looked like it
was against me and I should quit and I
should go do something else
for whatever reason in my heart told me
I can't quit now I have to keep going
and just through sheer perseverance and
and adjusting and developing the skill
set and getting better and becoming more
skilled I slowly got better and now here
we are you know my main channel has over
2 million subscribers and 300 million
views and it's only because I didn't
quit on my dreams when everybody else
would have quit
and I want the same thing for you if you
still love the thing that you're doing
it may not make sense right now it may
not be practical right now you don't
know how it's all going to work out
awesome you have to keep going or you're
going to regret it uh just quick story I
remember meeting the friend of mine in
Orlando a number of years ago just just
as I was about to start taking off so
maybe five years ago or so in Orlando
and he was telling me that that he's
going to be the next garyvee and and
that I'm gonna go off and be the next
big YouTuber and let's go build this
thing and like cheer each other on and
he posted something maybe two years ago
on his Instagram saying
I'm at Evan in Orlando and he showed you
know posted the picture of us having a
you know Starbucks in Orlando and I told
him I was gonna be the next garyvee and
he was going to go off and be the next
big YouTuber
and Evan went off and did it and I
didn't do my part
he just didn't have enough momentum he
just stopped start and stopped and
started and stopped and he didn't do it
and he has a lot more natural Talent
Charisma energy
um than I do
I think we both have an equal level of
kind of care and love and wanting to
serve and help but he he was way more
gifted naturally than me the only
difference is I just kept going
I loved it and I didn't want to quit on
it and now he regrets that he didn't
take the action now he's off doing it
he's chasing his dreams down he's he's
back on the horse and creating more
content and trying to be that next
person but he regrets not having hustled
as much as I did over the you know three
four years between us meeting and I
don't want that for you you've got a
dream energy passion you know you can
give something great to the world if you
love it you have to find a way to keep
going if you don't love it quit
immediately like get out of that
business if you hate it if you'd love it
it just hasn't worked out yet you have
to keep going okay so it's a three-step
process to know if you should quit and
how to keep the momentum going on your
dreams let's go step number one is make
the big decisions in your life with your
heart and the small ones with the head
big decisions with the heart small ones
with the head here's the thing your head
is designed to keep you safe your head
only understands a world that currently
exists it's logical it's practical it's
survival mode it keeps you safe it knows
what already exists
the problem is your heart wants to
create something new your heart is
telling you to go off and do something
that's never been done before so the
fact that you want to step outside what
your parents have done and what your
community does what your family has done
is not safe it's not practical it's not
logical you want to create and burst
something new that's what entrepreneurs
do so often the big ideas that you have
your head and your heart are they're not
aligned they're fighting your heart
wants to do this thing you love it you
know it's inside you like I gotta make
this thing but your head's thing you
can't do that you don't have the school
schooling education resources
connections money you can't go off and
do that go get the safe job right and so
often the head wins out because we live
in scarcity but your heart knows you're
capable of more and you're frustrated
with your life you have to make the big
decisions in your life with your heart
we're not making some list of pros and
cons that's your head thinking don't do
that big decisions with your heart and
then you use your head to help you
figure out the plan like
your heart tells your head we're doing
this head we're doing this okay no
options now help me figure out you're
the smart one help me figure out how to
actually make it happen big decisions in
life with your heart small ones with the
head number two is understand that your
purpose comes from your pain this is a
key theme in my new book built to serve
your purpose comes from your pain your
purpose is to help other people who
currently are what you used to be think
about what you struggled with what you
suffered through there are so many
people who are currently struggling with
the exact same thing you represent hope
to them you can help them you can guide
them you can save them
but you have to be out there creating so
if the idea that you have the dream that
you have is in service to the people who
currently are who you used to be and
you're going to reach back and help them
you have to keep going that that that's
going to fill you up for life I love
helping entrepreneurs so much because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur in
my first business when I felt worthless
I love modeling success and and teaching
you guys about all these famous
entrepreneurs and what they've done
because that's how I got out of the hole
that I was in right Bill Gates saved my
first company his story did right so
that's all I've done now for the past 20
years 20 years of of trying to now get
back and help out other entrepreneurs
and so if your purpose in your business
and what you want to create is coming
from that pain point that you went
through and you want to help others not
suffer as much you have to keep going
because that's going to fill you up for
the rest of your life and number three
is ask yourself what would you do if
money wasn't a problem a lot of times we
quit because money is a problem and that
is a practical reality of being an
entrepreneur money is often a problem
you haven't figured out yet how to make
it a success you haven't figured out
with my YouTube channel at the beginning
I didn't know how to make it a success I
wasn't making any money I wasn't getting
any views no comments no subscribers
right you haven't figured out the path
yet but if money wasn't the problem what
would you do would you still be doing
the same thing this is what often
separates the people who just have the
maniacal commitment to keep going and
have the momentum and energy sustained
to keep going where most logical sane
people would quit and give up because
they just love the thing that they're
doing so much if the reason you're doing
it is just chasing opportunity You're
Gonna Lose You should quit if you're
just chasing opportunity because because
this year is the year of XYZ right
whatever product or service if you're
just chasing down an opportunity then
get out because you're gonna go up
against people who love what they're
doing right if it's you who's just
chasing opportunity going up against
somebody who loves the thing
You're Gonna Lose they're gonna beat you
every time you might have this small
tiny window of success and then you have
to hop to the next thing hop to the next
thing and hop to the next thing never
have any sustained success because you
don't actually love the thing that
you're doing are you gonna come home and
be frustrated and angry and upset and
never really fulfilled so the reason
that you're chasing down the thing money
is important it's just not number one
it's got to be in your top five but if
you had all the money in the world what
would you spend your time doing and then
make sure that whatever business you're
in right now is just a smaller version
of what you would be doing because
that's the dream that you want to work
towards
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there had a not procrastinate best way I
found is you create a calendar so you
create a calendar and you put in your
calendar the habits that will lead you
towards success right so you have ideas
for what you want to create amazing